hopefully i can hit that 10 yard number
and
let it roll right next to hole
[Music]
yes sir oh maybe go in hey out of the
gates
right there baby cheers just lay up to
there that's all we do
nice layout teamwork
[Music]
[Music]
let's go baby is right
i think he did oh
wow well that's good hey
sorry partner they're probably hurting
inside right now
wow wow something huh that's
unbelievable i'll take that
partner thanks
oh he's walking oh he's walking inside
nice nothing no play
kind of like that cheyenne that's kind
of what i was trying to articulate
at the hill oh here it comes let it pick
up a little pace as it comes back down
oh thank you oh my goodness and then
give my man a putt that's true
all right phil dude come on
that's screaming right on the good line
again come on
shot
[Music]
you see where the six is that one's good
go back yep okay
wow all right so hill's closer by about
a half an inch
maybe a quarter inch
oh you didn't think i was gonna miss
that did you
miss those you don't miss those no
charles there's a bear
wow packers don't like bears
you're very easy boys like that yeah got
to drive the stuff right guys man the
three great you're talking about
oh my goodness i like it a little more i
try to be a little more balanced now
you were doing like straight this year
that's like you don't like the left foot
forward anymore huh
jesus pours it in away
good good pop go ahead and find that
thing came back left
did it really yeah
did he walk it in aaron thank you
harder my man
oh man i try that's good
i like the emotion there that's good
good try partner
aaron rodgers to win the match
there it is that away partner let's go
partner yep come here
whoa great job
ready to go tom thanks thank you guys
good playing great playing my man
great player
thanks for being here thank you hope
you're not ready for football season
like this
yeah we'll see what's gonna be tough
enough this week
way to go okay with some nice birdies
you guys played it was insane today
that's what i'm talking about i thought
we played okay